difícil acceso al agua potable y un
sistema de alcantarillado con fallas son
las condiciones ideales para el cólera
cuya bacteria se propaga a través del
agua en Siria donde el conflicto se
estanca en la pobreza aumenta están
todos los requisitos para la
contaminación
mi hijo está enfermo y ha tenido vómitos
y diarrea lo llevé al centro y nos
recibieron muy bien nos explicaron la
gravedad de la enfermedad en Líbano el
cólera había desaparecido desde 1993
desde hace un mes la enfermedad ha
resurgido particularmente en los campos
de refugiados donde las condiciones
higiénicas son deplorables la situación
es especialmente preocupante en Haití la
semana pasada el número de casos se
duplicó dos mil personas están
infectadas la mitad de los casos son
niños menores de 14 años Las Guerras y
los desplazamientos de población pero
también la crisis climática favorecen la
epidemia de có las sequías las
inundaciones todos estos fenómenos
meteorológicos rompen el acceso al agua
potable como en Pakistán o aquí en
Nigeria las epidemias son cada vez más
frecuentes y más mortíferas la mejor
defensa contra el cólera sigue siendo la
vacunación pero ante la explosión de la
demanda las vacunas son limitadas la OMS
lo ha decidido será una sola dosis
frente a las dos anteriores
la estrategia de la dosis única demostró
su eficacia en epidemias anteriores
aunque las pruebas sobre la duración de
la inmunidad son limitadas sin embargo
Es evidente que la situación está lejos
de ser ideal y que el racionamiento solo
debe de ser una solución temporal en los
casos más graves el Cooler ha provoca
una deshidratación severa y puede matar
en pocas horas pero las posibilidades de
supervivencia son altas y el paciente es
tratado rápidamente